va tout de suite retrouvé en direct de
genève notre envoyé spécial olivier de
care en flex bonsoir bonsoir même
olivier vous vous trouvez en compagnie
de gabriel galice président de
l'institut international de recherche
pour la paix à genève et vous allez donc
les interviewés sur cette rencontre et
avoir son analyse
oui effectivement
stéphanie à vous lisiez l'une des choses
qu'on retient ce soir c'est que cette
rencontre est bien malgré des
divergences
elle s'est déroulée sans une hostilité 1
c'est ce qu'ont souligné les deux chefs
d'état ce soir à l'issue de ce sommet
alors on va en parler avec vous un
docteur gabriel galice merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation
ici à genève alors finalement cette
rencontre a été utile
il semble que oui on l'a déjà dit mais
il est toujours utile de se parler pour
lever les équivoques et puis se
connaître déjà parce que ils s'étaient
déjà rencontrés dans le passé mais pas
dans leurs fonctions actuelles
visiblement le premier contact semble
avoir été positif je vous invite à vous
tourner vers la caméra pour nous
répondre sur cette question et
maintenant à quoi est ce qu'on peut
s'attendre dans les relations entre les
états unis et la russie
à côté il faudrait déjà que un certain
nombre de dossiers contentieux
s'apaisent nous allons voir si c'est le
cas dans dans les semaines et mois qui
viennent les dossiers chauds et puis
dans un deuxième temps je pense qu'il
faudrait qu'on s'oriente vers une
approche multilatérale des problèmes là
on était dans le bilatéralisme et vous
savez que la meilleure approche seule
approche multilatérale parce que le
monde ne se réunit pas autour de la
russie et les etats unis c'est à dire
que chacun doit parler aux autres
nations vont discuter tous ensemble il
faut qu' il faut qu'à l'onu qui à
l'assemblée qui a la prérogative pour
ces rencontres là se rencontrent
discutent de tous les thèmes des
conflits de la paire au 21ème siècle
quel l architecture de sécurité quels
sont les contentieux quels sont les
modes de régulation
quels sont les systèmes de défense
collective qui sont mis en place voilà
ce qui est à l'ordre du jour pour un
chercheur pour la paix en tout cas un
chercheur pour la paix finalement
comment est-ce qu'ils analysent les
paroles à la fois de joe biden et de
vladimir poutine ce soir qui ont été
dites au aujourd'hui c'est une bonne
entrée en matière comme on dit en suisse
et à genève en particulier il faut
entrer en matière entrée en matière
c'est commencé à ouvrir les pages du
livre donc le l'entrée en matière est
positive maintenant il faut donner du
contenu à la matière il faut finaliser
les choses il faut aller au delà
est ce l'enjeu de l'étape suivante il
faut confirmer le premier pas qui a été
fait à genève ça veut dire l'étape
suivante est bien intégré d'autres états
dans les discussions bien sûr ça veut
dire qu'il faut intégrer tout le monde
et je pense que le nu et le forum
approprié pour ça il ya
l'eau est sérieux il ya un certain
nombre d'autres organismes
mais l'onu est l'organisme qui doit
fédérer toutes les réflexions et tous
les partenaires pour éviter de rentrer
dans des jeux un petit peu biaisée de la
diplomatie bilatérale ce qu'on peut
noter aussi ce soir à l'issue de cette
rencontre et à l'issue aussi de la
tournée européenne de joe biden s'est
finalement joe biden aujourd'hui il
parle en tête à tête avec le président
de la confédération russie ce qui ne
fait pas avec emmanuel macron par
exemple il ne l'a pas rencontré en tête
à tête
comment est ce que vous le compris vous
le vous le comprenez il l'a rencontrée
dans d'autres occurrences il l'a
rencontrée fontainebleau il l'a
rencontrée à brégançon
c'est positif mais je crois que ça n'a
pas débouché
je crois qu'il ya rien de tel que de
discuter plutôt avec les bosses
effectivement il y en a qui semble plus
décisif que d'autres dans ce jeu là et
ça pose la question là derrière de
l'union européenne et les états membres
de l'union européenne quel jeu joue t-il
et un certain nombre de dossiers là
derrière notamment nord stream 2 qui ont
fait apparaître des divergences au sein
de l'union européenne
donc maintenant il va falloir que tout
ça aille dans le bon sens et que tout le
monde il retrouve ses intérêts parce que
chaque état a ses intérêts propres
c'est normal qu'un intec 1 et à défendre
ses intérêts s'ils doivent pas et
égoïstes ils doivent être négociées
doivent être complémentaires à ceux des
autres mais ils peuvent être divergents
et c'est la règle du jeu diplomatique
faire croire que les que les intérêts
sans naturellement convergence et naïf
donc il ya des divergences on les
examine et on trouve des solutions pour
conclure votre regard sur le fait que
désormais bien il y à leur tour un des
ambassadeurs dans les capitales
respectives des les puissances et 1 une
belle avancée
bien sûr c'est c'est le premier pas
c'est le premier pack qui doit être
suivi et d'un certain nombre d'autres
espérons qu'il ne tarde pas à venir
merci beaucoup docteur gabriel galice
d'avoir répondu à nos questions ce soir
en direct de genève je vous là je le
rappelle vous êtes président de
l'institut international de recherche
pour la paix à genève mais voilà
stéphanie donc ici à genève et bien le
calme revient on n'entend plus les
sirènes qu'on a pu entendre tout au long
de la journée notamment ce matin à
l'arrivée du cortège des deux chefs
d'état et puis ce soir avant leur départ
les deux hommes qui se sont envolés qui
ont désormais quitté genève après ce
sommet inédit
qui s'est déroulé à la ville à la grange
aujourd'hui ce que vous nous avez fait
suivre merci merci à vous infiniment
olivier de care en flèche